كويسه
كرامون
هذه القيمه
حدث مفصلي في تاريخ العلاقات الصينيه
العربيه
وتقول ستقوت العلاقات وتعاون بين الصين
ودول العربيه نحو مستقبل اجمل بكل تاكيد
بين الصين
وتقاسمت السراء والضراء في التيار
العولمه الاقتصاديه
تتماسك في الحق ولحداله في العالم المتغير
ولا المتقلب وبلورت من خلالها روح صداقه
الصينيه العربيه المتماثل في التضامن
وتازر والمساواه والمنفع المتبادله
والشمول والاستفاده المتبادله العربيه
حيث نتبادل دعم ثابت في لقاضايا المتعلقه
بالمصالح على حيويه للجانب الاخر
في قضيه عقيق احلام
نهضه الامومه
الفريق الواحد في المعركه ضد جاي حدا
فيروس
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الصيني العربيه
القائمه على تعاون الشامل والتنميه
المشتركه للمستقبل الافضل قويه لا تنقطع
تعتبر المساواه ولما فعل متبادله قوه
دافعه لا تنظر لصدقه الصينيه العربيه يحدث
تعاون الصيني العربي
المتبادل بين الجانبين
27 مليار دولار امريكي
وتنفيذ اكثر من 200 مشروع في اطارتها في
بناء الحزام وطريق التي عادت بلا خير
على قرابه
الصينيه العربيه
تتبادل الحضرتين الصينيه العربيه هل هي
عجب
وتسجلان فصولا تاريخيا رائعه من التعلم
المتبادل والاستفاده لمتبادله
نستلهم الى حكمه من الحضاره العريقه
للجانب الاخر
وننشر سويا
لاهتمام في السلام ودعوه الى الانسجام
والالتزام بالتعهدات والسعي وراء الحق
مدافع عن الاصاله
على الصراع على حضرات
وندعوا سويا الى الحوار بين الحضارات
ونلاحظ التمييز الحضاري
ونحافظ على تنوع الحضاري في العالم
دخل العالم مرحله جديده من التراب وتحاول
تغيرات جديده وعميقه
باتت رغبه الشعوب العربيه في السلامه
والتنميه اكثر الى حاحا
واشتدت نداءتها الداعيه الى الانصاف
والعداله
بين الصين
العربيه
اوثق بين الصين والدول العربيه
بما يعود بمزيد من الفوائد على الشعوب
الجانبين ويساهم في قضيه تقدمي للبشريه
و17
بالاستقلاليه والسيالات المصالحه المشتركه
يدعم الجانب الصيني جهود الدول العربيه
لاستكشاف طرق التمويه التي تتماشى مع
الظروفها الوطنيه
وتحكم في مستقبلها ومصيرها في ايدها
ويحرس الجانب الصيني على التحميق الثقه
لتراتيجيه المتبادله مع الجانب العربي
وتبادل الدعم الثابت في ما ساعي الجانب
الاخر الى الحفاظ على السياده البلاد
والسلام الاراضي ولا الكرامه الوطنيه وعلى
الجانبين تماسك سويا بمبدا عدم تدخل في
شؤون الداخليه
المشروع على الدول الناميه
و120
على التنميه الاقتصاديه وتعزيز تعاون
القائمه على الكسب المشترك من ضروري تعزيز
الموحمه بين استراتيجيات التنمويه وبناء
على حزام وطريق بجوده عاليه
ومن ضروري تطويد تعاون تقليدي في مجالات
الاقتصاد وتجاره وطاقه والبوميه تحتيه
وغيرها
خطاب النمو المساعده مثل كاميرا خضراء
والاستثمار والماليه
وفتح افاق جديده في مجالات الطيران
والفضاء والاقتصاد الرقمي والاستخدامات
السلميه
لطاقه النوويه
وتعامل الفعال مع تحديات الكبرى القائمه
مثل امن الغذاء وطاقه
مع جانب العربي على تنفيذ مباره
و14
على السلامه
الامن المشترك
يدعم الجانب الصيني الجانب العربي في
ايجاد حلول
السياسيه للقضايا الساخنه والشائكه بلا
حكمه العربيه
ونحو المجتمع الدولي
علاء احترامه الشعوبه شرق الاوسط
باعتبارها
السياده
الطاقه ايجابيه تخدم الامن والاستقرار في
الشرق الاوسط
ويرحب الجانب الصيني
في تعزيز السلام والامانه في الشرق الاوسط
علينا تعزيز تبادل الحضاري وزياده التفاهم
والثقه المتبادله
من ضروري توسيع نطاق تبادل الافراد
وتعميق تعاون على الانسان وثقافي وتبادل
الخبرات في الحكمه والاداره
ومن ضروره رفض
الاسلام فوبيا
بشكل مشترك
واجراه تعاون في نزعه التطرف
ورافع ربط الارهاب
بيعرق او دين بعينها
ومنها ضروري تكريس قيم البشريه المشتركه
المتمثله في السلام والتاميه والانصاف
والعداله والديمقراطيه والحريه
والنصب قدوه للتواصل والاستفاده المتبادله
بين الحضارات في العصر الجديد
راينا بارتياح
انه تم الاتفاق في هذه القمه على العمل
بكل جهود على بناء المجتمع الصيني العربي
للمستقبل المشترك نحول عاشر الجديد
مع وضع الخطوط العريضه لخطه تعاون شامل
بين الصين
تطور العلاقات الصينيه العربيه
على تنفيذ الاعمال الثمانيه المشتركه
خلال سنوات الثلاثه الى على خمسه القادمه
التي تغطي المجالات الثمانيه التاليه
تدعيم التاميه الامن الغذائي الصحه
التنميه الخضراء والابتكار امن طاقه
الحوار بين الحضارات
تاهيل الشباب
الامن والاستقرار
قد افاده الجانب الصيني الجانب العربي
بالمحتويات المفصله للاعمال الثمانيه على
المشتركه
وسيعمل مع الجانب العربي سويا على تنفيذها
في اسرع وقت ممكن
ايها الزملاء ولا اصدقاء
انا القضيه الفلسطينيه
تحوم السلام والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط
وتتحدى ضمير الاخلاقي
للبشريه على المحك
لا يمكن ان يستمر الظلم التاريخي الذي
يعاني منه الشعب الفلسطيني الى اجل غير
مسمه ولا تجوز المساومه على حقوق الوطنيه
مستقله
لن تقبل ربطه
على المجتمع الدولي ان يراسل الايمان بحل
دولهتين وتماسك بمبدا الاراضي مقابل
السلام
والزياده المساعدات الانسانيه والامائيه
لفلسطين
للدفع الحل العادل والعدل للقضيه على
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
يرحب الجانب الصيني بتقدم المهم الاخير
الذي حققته جهود على العربيه للدفع
المصالح الداخليه للفلسطينيه
الورد الفلسطيني
ويدعم فلسطين على عدويه الكامله في الامم
المتحده
وسيواصل تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه الى
الجانب الفلسطيني
لدعمه لتنفيذ
المشاريع المعيشيه
كما سيزيد من التبرعات الى وكاله الامم
المتحده لاغاثه وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في شرق الادنى
كويت الزملاء اصدقاء
على المؤتمر الوطني العشرين بنجاح
حيث تم تحديث
الامه الصينيه على نحو شامل من خلال
التحديث الصيني
سي يلتزم الصين
بالحفاظ على السلامه في العالم وتعزيز
ضمير مشتركه
ودافع ببناء مجتمع المستقبل المشترك
للبشريه
وسيلتزم بكل ثبات في السياسه خارجيه سلميه
مستقله والدفاع عن العداله والانصافرين
شراك العلميه
بثبات
بجوده عاليه
لما يوفر فرصنا جديده
لكافه الدول بما فيها الدول العربيه من
خلال التنميه الجديده في الصين
ايها الزملاء
المحترمون والاصدقاء
ان القضيه العظيمه تبدا بالحلم
وتنجز بالعمل الملموس
روح الصداقه
العربيه شكرا لكم